بسم الله الرحمن الرح والسلام على رسول
الله
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد ك الوجيز
في كتاب الطهاره
يقول المؤلف ولا يجوز الاستجمار بالعظم
والروث
عن جابر رضي الله عنه قال نهى النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم ان يتمسح بعظم او ببعر
‏tell us that another thing that is
imperm for person to do
when
cleaning
himself after
using the rest is that a person use
a bone or some kind of
‏some kind of
dring from anotheral and we thisday
he cit theidence
musl on the auority of narrates the
propit
personlean himself do what
يقول ويستحب اذا استنجى ان ينتضح
ان ينتضح والانتضاح هنا المقصود به
ان الانسان اذا اي قضى حاجته
واستنجى بمعنى استعمل الماء
ان ياخذ شيئا من الماء كفا من الماء في
ينضحه على مذاكيره وعلى ثوبه
ردا للشيطان وزياده في النظافه
ودفعا للوسوسه
الوسوسه الانسان مثلا
يقوم وقد قضى حاجته ويشعر ر بان ثم بللا
مثلا فياتيه الشيطان فيوحي اليه ان هذا
من النجاسه او ان هذا الى اخره فسدا لهذه
الذريعه ينضح شيئا من الماء اليسير دفعا
للشيطان
وهذا امر اختلف فيه العلماء
ما بين مصحح للروايه ومضعف
ولنسمع قول المؤلف
ifan
that they take of thatinkle
on their private parts or on their
why this is
‏people
up
them up whers
they have on them have not clean not
clean until they can't even function any
‏may bring
whatضاح
[Silence]
قليل من الماء فينضح به مذاكيره لينفي عنه
الوسواس وهذا كلام تعريف الحافظ في الفتح
يقول عن سفيان بن الحكم الثقفي قال كان
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم اذا بال
يتوضا وينتضح
والحديث عند ابي داوود والنسائي وابن ماجه
وعند البيهقي في الكبرى وعن سعيد بن جبير
ان رجلا اتى ابن عباس فقال اني اجد بللا
اذا قمت اصلي فقال ابن عباس انضح بكاس من
ماء واذا وجدت من ذلك شيئا فقل هو منه
فذهب الرجل فماكث ما شاء الله ثم اتاه بعد
ذلك فزعم انه ذهب ما كان يجد من ذلك وهذه
القصه مذكوره
عند البيهقي في السنن الكبرى الاقرب ان
يقال هذا لمن وجد ذلك يعني لمن كان يعاني
من هذه الوسوسه فانه ينتضح ولا باس اذا
كان احد
يعاني من ما كان يعاني منه هذا الرجل الذي
جاء سائلا مستفتيا ابن عباس رضي الله
عنهما كما ذكر لنا سعيد بن جبير ير رحمه
الله فانه ينتضح والا ف
ليس في
اي الروايات
في الصحيحين وفي السنن
اييه مما يدل على ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم كان يفعل ذلك على الدوام او ك او كان
يو يعني يداوم على هذا الفعل صحيح يقول
سفيان بن الحكم كان رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم الى اذا بال توضا وانتضح كان من
صيغ
الاستمرار من صيغ التجدد عند الاصوليين
يعني كلما فعل فعل لكن
الروايات في هذا الباب قليله مختلف فيها
فاذا كان الانسان يعاني من هذه مساله فلا
باس ان ينتضح كما
امر ابن عباس soش
سفيان بن الحكم الثقفي
رضي الله عنه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏and would
that this is that person should do in a
constant way however
uponer exination we see that the
majority of narrations regarding the
propet's
custom the companions
عن this is something that ‏was
not
across the
cit a
incident in the time of
one of
students.
الحجاج بن يوسف الثقفي
مكه
ابن عباس
after
these thoughts and whispers that may
wness in mything
عض
سعيد
عink
[Silence]
‏off that
is more correct is that if a person has
this isue
if there is a need to do it a person
does it other it's not necessarily
customary to do it time
uses the restانه
سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يعلمنا
ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا وان
يزيدنا علما والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبي ‏B